a major incident has been declared there  a rescue operation is now underway now  it involves what has been described as a  small boat off the coast of Kent Sky  News understands that two Search and  Rescue helicopters a multitude of rnla  lifeboats and other UK and French Navy  boats are involved in the rescue  spokesperson for the maritime and Coast  Guard agency has confirmed that a  fishing vessel in the area is also  assisting in the rescue Kent Police the  Southeast coast Ambulance Service they  are also involved an air ambulance has  been sent to the scene just the scale of  the response I think it gives you an  indication of just how seriously this  incident has been taken and anything  that we hear as soon as we can confirm  uh we will bring it straight to you but  let's return